Get ready with me for a day at home.
I was influenced to buy these velvet non slip hangers
but I hate them so much.
It is so hard to get clothes on and off of them,
especially trying to do one handed.
These overalls
with this shirt are giving Little House on the Prairie vibes,
but I'm not even mad about it.
And this deodorant from Primarily Pure
is the only natural deodorant that actually works.
Trust me on this. If you've tried all natural deodorant,
you know that that is a bold statement,
but I have three different scents and they all work great.
I also use primarily Pure's cleansing oil
and purifying bar to wash my face.
Oops, and that happened anyway.
Back to low tox skincare products.
I've also been using dime beauty products.
I love their skincare and their perfumes.
I have the work skincare system
and it works great on my sensitive skin.
Felt cute and Tuesday date night are my two favorite perfumes.
Dime Beauty is the only perfumes I can use
that do not give me a headache.